all right it's from daily wire it says
months after an Ohio school high school
hosted a drag event featuring multiple
performers who encourage students to
explore their gender identities
one Mother wearing the same outfit as
one of the performers blasted school
board members over their alleged failure
to address parental concerns
so she came to the school board meeting
wearing one of the outfits
that that a drag performer at the school
had worn she was doing that to make a
point
as revealed by a previous report from
the daily wire and videos captured by
Libs of tick tock the gay straight
Alliance Club at Ankeny High School
invited drag queen performers in May for
their end-of-year meeting without
obtaining permission for administrators
one of the drag queens donned a
one-shouldered black leotard and long
black boots before performing a
provocative dance for students Kimberly
reichs the founder of Parental the
parental rights group Iowa Mama bears
noted during public comments at a Monday
school board meeting that officials have
neglected to provide the results of
their investigation halfway through her
remarks the mother of seven removed her
sweatpants and her jacket to reveal the
same outfit that the drag queen had been
wearing
she says in the in the clip she says
does this outfit make your head turn
does this outfit seem appropriate for
anybody uh here to see this is what the
man dressed like in front of your kids
so if this makes your head spin if this
pisses you off in any way shape or form
it should because I'm embarrassed to
stand here in the outfit that I'm in
today but I have to put a point to prove
that this outfit should not ever be
accepted in our schools anywhere
and that is a a
I mean a pretty brilliant maneuver on
her part
and it really does I think send a
message it makes the point
that
you know the absurdity just the abject
absurdity of all of this is that
you know
it is now considered
appropriate
for men to wear women's outfits
certain types of women out women's
outfits in context when it would not be
considered appropriate even for a woman
to wear them
I think this is a just a a perfect way
to prove that point
yeah she looks ridiculous wearing that
outfit at a school function it's just
not an appropriate outfit
it's not even appropriate for women and
if it's not appropriate for women it
would be it's not that it's less
appropriate it'll be even more
inappropriate for for men
obviously
you know the left is losing their faith
but uh we're not and a core part of that
faith is prayer I talk a lot about
stressful things all day and you might
feel a little overwhelmed with where the
country is going but I've got good news
Hollow can help you find some peace and
hope rooted not in the government or its
institutions but in God hallow has over
5 000 audio guided prayers meditations
and peaceful Christian music including
uh the rosary with Bishop Baron and Mark
Wahlberg the uh they've got Bible
bedtime stories with Jonathan Jonathan
Rooney and many more as well hello helps
you build and a daily routine and a
habit of prayer helps me to pray to
meditate and sleep better it's a huge
part of my daily routine and it should
be for you to get an exclusive
three-month trial of hallow at hello.com
Matt Walsh that's hello.com Matt Walsh
reclaim your piece in this crazy world
download hello today
yeah I point this out all the time with
uh with with the the drag shows where
they invite kids to it
this is what's insane about it one of
the many things that's insane about it
that if you were to take all those men
and keep everything the same
outfits are the same
performances are the same
the uh you know given tips the kids
running up there with money cash tips to
give to the performers keep all that the
same
but instead make them women
if that was the case then everyone would
probably agree that this is not
appropriate for kids
because if they're actual women rather
than men dressed up like women it
becomes what it is which is a burlesque
performance
drag is is male burlesque it is a male
burlesque performance
now you can feel however you feel about
burlesque performances and if you're an
adult and you're in Las Vegas and you
want to go to a to something like that
you can
but would anyone really think that it's
appropriate to bring a kid to a to a
burlesque
performance much less to have one at a
school
and anyone who suggested that you would
say well why why do you want this in the
school what's the point of all the
things of all the ways that we could use
the time you want to bring someone in
and we want to use the auditorium and we
could do something educational you want
to have a burlesque uh we we would
totally reject that for women but you
you
switch them out and make them men and
it's supposed to be now suddenly
acceptable
and that'll do it for us today as we
move over to the members block of the
show hope to talk to you uh then if not
talk to you tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]